this is the man suspected of killing
five people in norway espen anderson
he's now in custody
his attacks started at this supermarket
he used a bow and arrow as well as other
weapons
and left behind a traumatized town
kongsberg once known for making coins
now shaken by
nightmarish memories
i saw a man walking with an arrow in his
back a man with an arrow in his back
yes that was the off-duty officer who'd
been in the shop he told me to head home
there are still scars of this attack
and memories of chaos and fear
they heard our washers good i was nearby
then i came to the scene and then i
heard warning shots which the police
fired and then i saw some arrows but i
did not see the man he who had shot the
arrows
norway has a brand new prime minister
one of his first tasks
to try to sum up the feeling of grief
especially
police here say this appears to have
been terrorism it understood the suspect
had converted to islam some years ago
and was known to the security service
he'll be assessed by a psychiatrist
but for many here and across norway this
is bewildering the rates of violent
crime and murder are comparatively low
here so when it does happen
it resonates
right now we have opened the church and
it will be open throughout the day
people can come here to get someone to
talk to or be with someone they can sit
in silence or light a candle
norwegian police believe people were
killed at random
they say bratton has admitted his guilt
and has been charged with murder
adam parsons sky news